good morning everyone it is awesome
awesome to be here on Monday morning I
always like to start with an exercise so
if you can if you do not have any
mobility impairments if you could please
stand up
I know it's Monday morning sorry all
right if you could raise your hands you
have the right idea if you could raise
both of your hands in the air I'm sorry
if you're holding a cup of coffee or a
laptop okay I think I think there's some
people I think you can raise your hands
just a little bit higher I really get
that stretching because we're at the
beginning of the conference some of you
may have been stuck this morning on the
subway alright so for those of you who
can see the slide don't look at it but
on three we're all gonna raise our hands
just a little bit more okay ready one
two three
stretch all right
you can also sit down the point of this
exercise is you can always reach a
little bit higher I had nice slides for
this so cool Coco I also have that
activity because sometimes it takes a V
to gets up for a little bit good morning
everyone the the title of my talk today
is a few good public servants how great
analysis inspires action and I'm really
really excited you guys I took a look at
the agenda for the conference upcoming
and it looks like a really really
jam-packed panel lineup you all have for
the next couple days and so there's a
few things that I would like to talk
through uh-oh do we lose the yeah
it's fine I can do it off memory that's
good
cool alright so you can always reach a
little bit higher moving forward um so
I'm actually here to tell you all of few
stories there are a handful of different
stories I want to talk about you have
here just a map of the United States and
because I think for a lot of us who work
in data and analytics a lot of our work
is actually about storytelling so I'm
going to tell you all a few stories from
my time working in DC at the Obama White
House for the last decade or so helping
to stand up Boston's data team and an
analytics team and then I'm going to
talk about how I traveled a bit
throughout the country and how I landed
in New York City even though I am
actually a native of the state of
Massachusetts the great state of
Massachusetts and so the the story goes
I had spent quite a while in DC and a
lot of things have changed since 2016 I
actually gave a PI data keynote in
October 2016 I think a couple weeks
right before the election happened and
although I think if anybody turns on the
news you may know that a lot of things
have changed I'm going to talk about
today a few things that have remained
the same regardless of where you are in
our country and I think a huge part of
that has to do with continued civic
engagement which i think is particularly
true here in New York City this is
actually my first time living here over
the last year and I've really seen how
active you all are and I think what is
truly remarkable as I think within the
civic tech and data community just how
active folks are in policy spaces this
is definitely not true I will not name
other cities but there are a lot of
other cities out there where the turnout
is not the spectacular on a Monday
morning and here in New York City you
know I definitely within the mayor's
office of data analytics at City Hall
the work that we do builds upon a
foundation of incredible work that has
happened you have here a photo of quite
a few students at the very first
hackathon held inside of City Hall
here in New York City it should be no
surprise that as part of this hackathon
as this hack League hosted by beta NYC
and cs4 all within do we hear the kids
built quite a few things that I actually
wanted to scale throughout the cities so
there's a lot of incredible talent here
happening within New York but I'm
actually going to start today's
conference session talking about
sidewalks I have a very very good friend
of mine who describes public policy as
thinking of a sidewalk and thinking of a
sidewalk curb I think what is really
interesting for a lot of you is when you
think about public policy first a lot of
people really struggle to define what is
public policy I think even people who
may have MPP MPA degrees really struggle
with that and she always talks about the
fact that a sidewalk curb ramp is public
policy actually in action and I know
people don't think about this but if you
think about millions and millions of New
Yorkers who walk down the sidewalk it
the fact that the sidewalk does not just
end when you reach the street the fact
that it slopes down and the fact that
individuals with mobility impairments
parents with kids and strollers can not
just fall off where the sidewalk ends
that's actually public policy in action
and I think for a lot of you who work in
data and analytics I certainly spend a
lot of my day-to-day time trying to
figure out how do I demonstrate what we
do on a day to day basis within the data
team so what is
what is this analog what is the image of
analytics in action and I have a fetus
at you so the the closest image I
currently have is this it is on the left
hand side I just took a local law that
actually names the mayor's office of
data analytics we'll talk about it in a
little bit we got actually written into
the city charter late last year and on
the right hand side we got some code up
and what was really interesting is we
had a new data scientist join our team
two weeks ago and Adrian Schmo Kerr who
is the deputy chief analytics officer
said she walked over to our data
scientists screen and she literally had
a local law up on one side and code up
on the other side and I said well that's
a pretty good visual of thinking about
how analytics works within government in
particular in in local government it is
thinking about the intersections of
these pieces the piece that's actually
missing in that image that you all saw
is very clear that this person is coding
it's late at night and the reading is
this component that I sometimes think a
lot of analysts forget and a lot of
techies forget which is you have to talk
to people this is actually a framework
within the civic service design lab
which is hosted by NYC opportunity a
sister agency to us at the mayor's
office of data analytics and Mari who
heads up that team we were sitting down
I think a week ago and she said a thing
that we always do and we have to do in
government is talk to people and I know
it sounds so incredibly simple but is
something that people often forget to do
and I think I'm particularly in
government and I won't speak to other
industries that are represented here in
the room today but in particular to
government to local government it is
actually a part of our jobs to
constantly talk to people because we
deliver services for them because we
engage with them
every day and because ultimately we're
accountable to those that we speak to
I've been up I actually cut this out and
it's in my office I've been obsessed
about this tweet that Nate Silver
tweeted I'll read it out loud so
everybody can can see it if you want to
be a good data scientist you should
spend 49 percent of your time developing
your statistical intuition how to ask
good questions of the data another forty
nine percent of your time on domain
knowledge improving overall
understanding of your field and only two
percent on methods per se and this to me
was a little bit of an aha moment
because a lot of those percentages can
only be accounted for by actually
talking to people and so I think this is
particularly true in government where
there's been a huge push to be more data
driven to do a lot of data for good
initiatives and I think it's in becoming
increasingly important for all of us to
work on responsible analytics and we can
only do that when we engage with
stakeholders and and with individuals um
I want to pause for a moment these are
not images from the city of New York
these are two images that I've just kept
in my photo Bank because for anyone who
really really likes complex problems
welcome to government so these are two
photos from server rooms that I've
collected over time not the city of New
York here you have some wires next to
some water next to a plugged in toaster
oven on the right hand side you have
wires that I swear were really organized
like two days before that photo and then
we opened up the closet again and then
it looked like that two days later and I
show you all these photos not just so
you can have a chuckle on Monday morning
but because a lot of the work that we do
is really really messy and I don't just
mean on the data front you all are used
to dealing with a lot of data and trying
to figure out how to make sense of all
of that information for us with the
government it's also everything else
it's the policies it's the programs it's
the agencies the people who are
underlying them and I think for anyone
who really really enjoys a challenge
this is constantly top of mind is if you
look at that and you're like I want to
fix that I want to clean that up I want
to help people have cleaner closets
server closets it's a lot of the work
that we do and I think that it's really
really easy oftentimes when you all see
what governments what agencies even the
rest of this presentation that I'm about
to give and think wow it's so clean and
easy and da da da and I'm like it's
actually really messy it takes a lot of
effort a lot of work with by a lot of
teams in order to make sense of a lot of
what we're working on and so rewinding
to 2015 I was feeling pretty good about
myself I was at the city of Boston we
had done what I kind of shared with you
all we were talking to people we were
making sure that we talked to a lot of
city agencies and better understood
what's happening
and we were doing some good work there
the data team we actually worked with
the fire department there and we build
out the building intelligence systems
tool and we integrated a ton of
information and we piloted a tool where
firefighters and fire dispatch could
actually on demand be able to figure out
what kind of hazards were located where
within particular buildings this is of
course incredibly important to any
public safety response for any city and
what was really neat about this was that
it was actually one of the firefighters
ideas there in Boston he had just like
if you may go to Europe and you're like
I'm going to this particular city and
I'm gonna drop a bunch of pins down of
all the cafes and restaurants that I
would like to go he had actually created
a Google map where he just dropped a
bunch of pins of buildings that had
hazards in them and we said actually we
can take that we can
we can help you actually build a tool
for that and so we feel pretty good you
know built a couple of things this is an
image of the mayor's dashboard this is
Dan Coe his former chief of staff in
Boston for mayor Walsh and we felt
pretty good we actually delivered road
hitting dashboards in the city I will
never live this down and I never want
this title again but I was known as the
dashboard Queen which I never got that
title now I've told you all and and what
was really interesting is another big
component of great analytics of great
analysis is you want your information
your data to be visual and to be
actionable and so for us that meant how
do we get in front of the executives and
the leaders and what is something that
they actually look at every single day
well just so happens a wall across from
the mayor's desk within his office and
this was something that the mayor's
still to this day uses think about a lot
of the dashboard requests for anybody
who works in probably finance or really
any industry your executives or
leadership is looking for a dashboard
they are looking for what our insights
so the mayor would look at the
information I was presented to him and
be able to call Chiefs to be able to
call departments and actually ask some
questions why have your numbers gone up
over the last season over the last week
what are some things that we could do to
fund better programs and so for us this
is really a starting point and so I
again feeling pretty good about myself
build some shiny things within the city
of Boston and got a call one day from
the White House and I had worked within
the Obama White House within the
Domestic Policy Council in 2012-2013 and
had gotten a call in April of 2016 and
they said would you be interested in
coming
back and I said you only have a couple
months left so I'm not exactly sure what
you're going to be doing in the last
couple months of the administration and
then they said well you should talk to
DJ Patil about it and I said okay and no
one can tell DJ this in case you know
him but DJ who is the very first US
chief data scientist and who many folks
say co-founded Co coined the term data
scientist for anyone here who has the
actual title I hopped up on phone with
DJ and then ended up flying down to DC
and he said you know what's really
interesting is that we're trying to make
sustainable a lot of the work that we're
doing within the administration and one
of the ways to do that is how do we
infuse the practices within state and
local governments because there's all
this incredible work that's been done at
the federal level but what does it
actually matter if we're not touching
people's lives on the ground and so I as
I usually do is like DJ what am I going
to be working on Who am I gonna be
working with and he said you should come
up with your own operating thesis I said
I am sold
I will come to DC on that premise I will
fly down over a weekend and come work
for a couple months and it just so
happens that I arrived and I really
really thought that I would be working
on sensor technology drones IOT really
anything buzz worthy at the national
level working in partnership with state
and local governments it actually
happened that there were a series of
incredibly terrible shootings July 2016
and it had stirred up a federal
conversation across states and counties
and cities about what were we doing
around criminal justice reform and the
criminal justice system and it just so
happened that I was on the data and
Technology team working with DJ working
with Meghan Smith the u.s. chief
technology officer
I ended up working on the criminal
justice system and I didn't expect that
at all and I won't go too far into the
weeds here to share with you all but the
very first thing I did because I knew
nothing about the system was to talk to
people and that's when I said a couple
slides ago this is something that
President Obama has done again and again
and that I think many many great leaders
doesn't matter if it's in the public or
private sector do they talk to people
and so as with that that I really
started to understand that in these last
six or seven months as a part of this
work I would be faced with a much bigger
challenge that wasn't just about
building shiny tools or dashboards or
visualizations it was how do we tell the
story using data and technology to make
national and federal change and this was
one slide that I probably have put a
couple thousand miles down traveling
around the country with this one
sentence every year I'll have a million
people cycle through 30 100 local jails
costing twenty billion dollars the three
largest mental health facilities
throughout the country are the country's
three largest jails which I will not
name here and in those local jails 64
percent have a mental illness 68 percent
have a substance use disorder and 44
percent have chronic health problems and
for us when we talk about the criminal
justice system we look at what the
Pareto analysis is of what all the
people who are in those systems and
whether or not they're getting the help
that they need and for me as simple as
these two slides are another big note
about great analysis inspiring action is
to filter your message and to get it to
a point where you can be crisp about
exactly what you are talking about what
the problems and issue areas are
and to actually grab people with what
you're talking about and so I'll take
all back in time I have since visited I
think at least five if not more jails
throughout the country county jails
throughout the country and my very first
experience was at Cook County Jail the
largest single-site facility larger than
I think ninety plus acres and we had
gone there was the very first facility
that I had visited um and I'll never
forget that moment when we were exiting
the facility and we ended up stuck in
traffic and I had never been anywhere
never mind picture to jail that you
could be stuck in traffic on the way out
because there were so many individuals
and workers who were there and it took
us 45 minutes to actually get outside of
the jail facility and to me it was more
of this understanding in context of just
the universe that we were in within a
policy issue area so if you think back
to that Sidewalk image this is this is
another image for all of you to take
away with the other thing that I'll say
just as a note I think for anyone who's
like oh none of my data is in exactly
the way that I wanted and I can't do the
analysis and it take me 99 percent of my
time to actually get my data shaped the
right way one of the jails that we
visited was really really proud they
slid a one-pager over to us and they
said we've never been able to accurately
count how many people we have in the
jail until recently here's a one-pager
of the counts male/female etc and for me
this was truly an understanding of I
think a lot of talent that is across the
entire country that is here in the room
there's some really incredible work that
can be done I think in public policy
just at the descriptive analytics side
for a lot of these jurisdictions for a
lot of these programs and for a lot of
these these public policy issue areas
and so of course you're like alright
Kelly if I've seen enough images like
show me some numbers and data what was
really interesting about the data-driven
justice initiative which was this
nationwide coalition of a lot of
different communities who joined and
signed on was that we did not try to
recreate the wheel and I highly
encourage all of you to remember that do
not try to recreate the wheel if you can
figure out who is working on a similar
challenge go talk to them and for us
this was identifying that the University
of Chicago this was raid ghani's former
group there for those of you who are
familiar a group of students actually
took a look at the data Johnson County
Kansas and based off integrating a few
of these different datasets they were
able to really look and say this is a
really compelling case on the right hand
side this finding a key predictor for
someone on the list was being
disconnected from mental health services
around two years since the last contact
and for us when we walked around the
country that all of those numbers people
said that cannot be right it cannot
possibly cost the county two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars per person on on
the low end of sending them to jail and
the more communities that we went to
there were some communities that had a
handful of high frequent utilizers
recycling in and out of jail and they
found that they had numbers upwards in
the millions that's how much their
various systems were trying to respond
to individuals who had mental health
issues and and needs and so for me again
when it comes to great analysis try to
figure out how can you tell that story
how can you encapsulate in such a way
that that you're really going to help
move move people along I'm going to try
to speed this up because I know I only
have a couple more minutes with you all
but I want to segue and start Chuck this
is a photo of New York City Hall in case
you've never visited I want to talk
about what that all means I've just told
you all
these stories all right Kelly you've
traveled a little bit you've gone to
different communities I got a call one
day to come interview for the chief
analytics officer position here we are
I'm gonna claim this but the best the
flagship data team throughout the
country and the mayor's office of data
analytics has been around in some form
or another for a decade and I think that
that is a testament in and of itself the
great work that the prior staff and
leaders on the team have done and for me
it was incredibly humbling to come here
because when I was in Boston when I was
working at the White House and even
before then this this is the team to
beat right this this is the team that's
working at the forefront and to be able
to say how do we actually chart out a
vision and a path was really really
interesting to me this is an image of
the New York City org chart for anyone
who thinks that they have a confusing
org chart at their organization this is
ours you can find it online and for us
this was really exciting we're here we
got ran into the org chart office of
data analytics and I always tell this
story because for me it is incredibly
important that we think about how to
sustain and to build data infrastructure
into our organizations and I think for
anyone who's paying attention to local
governments different cities across the
country people are trying to figure out
where do I put my data team should I put
it under IT should I make it an office
that reports into the executive office
should it be hitched under the various
agencies or programs like do I need a
data team for my marketing team do I
need a data team for my sales team and
for us we're really really lucky that we
got written into the org chart and that
has a lot to do with a lot of our our
team members and people over time being
really really crystal clear on
on what we're doing I we are here we are
a tiny dot for I'm gonna assume that
most of you know that this is a pale
blue dot Carl sake and look it up if in
case you don't know but for us within
the broader cosmos of New York City
it feels some days like where this dot
and I think for a lot of you not gonna
project here it might feel like you're
like this within your broader
organizations or that like one small
team that's working on data and
analytics and you're constantly trying
to explain what am i doing what is my
team doing what are these projects that
we're working on and I think it's really
really important to acknowledge just how
nimble you have to be our team is only a
team of ten and within the broader
ecosystem there are three hundred and
twenty-five thousand government
employees here in New York City it's the
third fourth largest workforce
government workforce throughout the
United States and we have over 125
agencies eight point six million New
Yorkers upon latest count and the budget
of the city is over ninety billion
dollars so some days it feels like
that's us this this tiny little tiny
little dot so I'm actually going to get
a little concrete here with all of you
now which is I've spent a lot of time in
government and private sector and I'm
not going to go into exactly what is
data science what do I think data
science is what do I think data science
in government is but I will put up this
slide which I've spent I think a year in
change working with the team on of what
is data analytics because it's not just
math and I think for a lot of people who
work within broader organizations but
certainly within governments there's
this question of like what are you
working on and what are the ways that
you can frame out what you're working on
and so for us is pretty straightforward
I think you can argue about the
semantics of all of these descriptive
analytics what is happening or has
happened diagnostic and
why is it happening predictive analytics
what will happen in the future
prescriptive analytics what should be
done about it
and I think what's incredibly
interesting for anyone who understands
public policy if you remember at the
very beginning is that your work can
only start on the left hand side your
work has to start at the left hand side
you have to understand everything that's
up here before you can actually move to
the right hand side there's no universe
where you could start with prescriptive
analytics without understanding what's
happening without understanding the
underlying data sorry I just had to get
on that soapbox for a moment and in
terms of what do we actually do I wanted
to share this because this may be
helpful depending on which industry that
you're actually in so the mayor's office
of data analytics within New York City
we do I think we do many things but
broadly chunked into these four advisory
analytics so in this case it's the phone
call that's hey we're doing something
can I get your advice for an hour can I
get on the phone with you or somebody
team so this is actually supporting
agencies on the methodology that they're
working on strategies or even with top
of mind within industry so we get a lot
of those calls and we take them the
second is mechanical analytics project
so this is I think what a lot of the
conference sessions will entail are
people who are working on very clear
this is my analytics question this is
the data set that we have and this is
we're actually trying to push forward on
this is our hypothesis that we're trying
to test we do those in partnership with
city agencies they're really really
interesting items to me which are
slightly different I think for us is
that we have an analytic SWAT team and
that means and we does not a separate
team within the team but that means that
we could deploy if there is an emergency
here in New York City the best example
of this was the Legionnaires outbreak
that occurred in 2015 the mayor's office
of data analytics or Moda as were known
we deployed to actually do a lot of the
number crunching and to integrate that
data in an emergency context
and so you can take that you can think
about what are some parallels what are
some fast turn analyses they need to
happen and last but not least executive
or legislative analytics this is a part
of working within local government
specifically working with in New York
City we do a lot of the work that is by
law required for us to do to actually
analyze so we have a lot of interesting
work to do there we do work on a lot of
analyses that will inform policy and so
while I cannot get into the details of
all of those analyses these are some
broad questions that we're currently
working on we work on helping people
count we work as advisers we work across
agencies and then we work to look at
what are some policy impacts or
assumptions or references that we should
be thinking about and I think if any of
these questions strike you as these are
actually really interesting questions
you yourself have that is the broader
context in which we work within the
mayor's office of data analytics is
thinking about what are some questions
that we have about the world that we
live in about New York City specifically
it just so happens we got to do that for
a living which is pretty cool what do we
do I encourage you to go online please
please please read a little bit more
about all of our work bitly slash Moda
and read on we've done a ton of work
supporting tenant anti-harassment
efforts throughout the years the
universal pre-k roll out really our work
spans spans a lot of different fields so
I'm going to try to wrap up relatively
quickly here as I noted toward the
beginning we've we are really really
fortunate and lucky here we are here to
stay and I think that is something that
is always a measure of success is when
people outside of your team without
outside of your organization are able to
notice you and understand you so we were
actually written in in December into the
New York City Charter which is in effect
the constitution of New York City
local law 2 to 2 of 2018 and this is
something that we're incredibly proud
about because it means that we are we
are moving forward and one day I don't
know what it will be like but we'll be
around for 40 years like some of our
partner agencies and offices I'm going
to talk and give one more plug on our
open data program and portfolio somebody
sent me a note on LinkedIn about our
open data program and I saw a few
conference sessions about what is
available on NYC open data and how to
navigate it we also in addition to
everything else that we work on also
manage and oversee the city's open data
program we have over 2,600 data sets
that are available online we are this
country's largest municipal data store
of free data on there some of our data
sets I think last year there were 10
million parking violation data sets like
you should actually go on there and
further explore it is an incredible
incredible resource and earlier in
September we actually launched the next
decade of open data in thinking about
what the future of this is going to look
like and not just be data open data for
compliances sake because it is a law
here in New York City that you're
required to publish your data if it is
public data but I know a lot of folks
are actually using the information so if
you look on the left-hand side here this
was really really neat the New York
Times had done a piece using the basis
of the piece was finding permits for
block parties throughout New York City
and they actually sent photographers out
so you can go look that up online and on
the right hand side this is a tool built
by I'm sure many of you have heard the
name Kris Wong formerly of the
Department of City Planning a day in the
life of an NYC taxi the point of great
analysis is how do you engage folks how
do you engage them in a way that they
may not actually be
expecting and I promised my deputy that
I would now talk about squirrels all the
time I was a little skeptical when she
said I had this great idea and we should
partner with the squirrel census and I
said all right and she won me over
because this has actually been an
incredible incredible story about the
usage of NYC open data first off I had
no idea that many people were passionate
about squirrels maybe it's like a New
York City thing but it happened this is
like taken off the squirrel census is an
incredibly passionate group of
individuals you'll see this is actually
a photo of adrian's desk because I
walked in one morning and burst out
laughing
she had a the data visualization from
the squirrel census done of Central Park
up by her desk and so for me continuing
to think about how do you engage using
the data how do you engage using
analytics is so so critical to the work
that we do have a little fun along the
way so now that I've talked to you a
little bit about everything that's done
throughout the country and a little bit
about what the mayor's office of data
analytics does I think the thing that I
want to close with is to remember that
it's not just our little team or your
little team but that there's a whole big
team out there of like-minded folks
what's really really been incredible is
that also over the last ten years as the
mayor's office of data analytics has
grown so have other data teams the fire
department the Buildings Department the
Parks Department across the city and so
I'm seeing like little data teams emerge
throughout all of these city agencies
and for me that is the point of all of
this work the point of all of this work
is not that people continue to come to
you the point is that there's other
people that they can go to throughout
the organization's and throughout the
the work that we do I struggled a lot as
a bus tone
into like put up in New York City story
image set up friends it's gonna do Good
Will Hunting which is what I usually do
if I'm not in New York City but I put
this up here in part because our work is
about finding your tribe as I talked
about but it's also about good
storytelling and I think for anyone who
has traveled outside of the United
States people's understanding of
American culture is like New York City
culture and it's basically anything that
happens on friends they'll just ask you
does that really happen in America and I
put this up because I always want you to
remember to tell that story to figure
out how to tell the story to find the
other people who can tell the stories
with you that's what great analysis is
all about that's what a lot of
incredible incredible public servants a
few good ones and I think an emerging
number of them have done these are just
photos
this is potluck from two or three weeks
ago but these are just photos over time
of the incredible people that I've
worked with and that I can continue to
call upon and I think for anyone here
who hopefully I have not talked your ear
off but if you're ever interested in
working for government working as a
civil servant as a public servant at any
point in your career
send me some you know would love to chat
a little bit more I hope you guys have
an incredible incredible time here for
the rest of the PI data conference I
just want to say a huge thank you to the
organizers and the folks who invited me
today and I hope this was a good kickoff
for you all this morning thank you
[Applause]